hey everybody its Jesse and uh today
we're showing it a lot done
and I actually want to try to get
through like a whole a whole process
usually I just work on random stuff and
I don't always get it done so I want to
go try to go start to finish and take
you through the process of creating a
custom post type in WordPress with
custom fields populating that with some
data getting that data pulling it into a
reactor and we're gonna make a template
in react to display that data and we
want that a user to be able to go to a
page and have that page automatically
generated with a unique URL so we're
gonna need to edit our server j/s file
to be able to handle that so I want to
get all of that done while I'm streaming
so that's a lot of stuff but I've done
it I don't want to say a lot but I've
done it you know three or four times
before you know recently so I think we
can get it done I'm gonna check the live
chat say hi hey everyone
so I apologize in advance if I'm a
little weird for this dream because I I
only got like five hours of sleep last
night
so I was up I ended up not being super
tired last night so I applied to speak
at some conferences which is kind of
exciting I've never applied to speak at
conferences before so we'll see what
happens
I don't really know if I if my
submissions were even any good because
I've never even seen anyone's submission
before but hopefully I at least get some
good feedback you know even if I get
rejected that would be kind of cool if
you want to see my um what I submitted
to some of the conference's it's
available online so check my Twitter I
sent out a link last night so that
people could actually check out my idea
for a talk and then this morning the
baby was up really early so anyway that
that's why I didn't get sleep but I'm
gonna try my best to stay focused I do
have one question for you all to start
someone asks what my Twitter handle was
Jeremy asks it's it's in the description
for this show it's just it's Jesse are
Weigel so jay esse r w e i GTL
and let me I had one problem so I really
wanted to get you all a link that you
could go to to see all the updates so I
started a dev branch that's gonna be
like the cutting edge stuff the latest
stuff that we're doing for this site and
that is going to be updated at our
server I don't know if anybody remembers
when we set up the load balancing but we
actually have three droplets running
node and react and we are only a load
balancing between two so I never shut
down that third droplet because I always
thought it would come in handy for
testing and today it has come in handy
so that's the droplet that I can just
give you the IP address for and you all
can can check it out now I did get it
working but I just tried to update it
and for some reason it quit working now
here's what I think happened my session
timed out when I was used logged into
the server and I didn't use usually used
p.m. to to start the server but I didn't
even set it up I just started it you
know with just a regular command just
npm run start and I never shut down the
server so right now I can't start the
new server because port 8080 is already
in use so normally I would shut it down
by pressing ctrl C right but that
doesn't work because at least I don't
think it works
I can sure you double check but I don't
think that's gonna work for me yeah how
do you shut down a node server from the
command line if it's not actually like
the process is not actually running in
my command line right now like I'm I
can't see it so if anybody knows how to
do that let me know and then I can get
this up and running and you all can have
a place where you can check out all the
latest stuff without having to download
this repository and run a local server
so I
I'll figure it out eventually but I just
figured maybe somebody is really
familiar with node and just knows
exactly what command I need okay Patrick
did have Patrick had a good comment he
asked about the on change event with
materialized so okay cool so I've gotten
the the command so let's go sudo kill
all node is that it
which other so anyway yesterday we
couldn't I couldn't get this select
thing to work and I said that I would
let you all know how I ended up getting
it to work so let me let me do that now
all right cool
so that works so if you go to let me
find the IP for you
I'll paste this IP address in the live
chat and it's the IP address is 1 6 2.2
4 3.8 6.67 and maybe if I can remember
I'll put it in the shared description so
anyway this will show the latest stuff
so this will actually show you that this
is working now all right so the only
thing this is the only thing that
actually has a working category right
now I'm pretty sure nothing else has
been put into categories but that is
working I'll show you how I got it
working in a second
also for some reason these borders on
this top one just start coming and going
I haven't replaced the borders with hrs
yet so I need to do that but I did get
this working so I have this little
toggle here and this is just changing
the state within the component so within
the component there's a display content
set automatically to false if it's false
it displays this when you click it it
sets the state to true and displays the
Falaise this and this one when you click
it it sets the state back to false so
let me show you the code for how I got
this working and then we'll get started
on on what I actually described in the
title in the description for this video
so
within that's material select that's
what we have so within material select
what I've done is basically just gotten
rid of all the materialized stuff so I'm
not initializing the materialized I
should give some background in case you
weren't watching yesterday and you're
not sure what I'm talking about I'm
using the materialized framework it's a
CSS framework it uses some jQuery stuff
and changes the Dom so it's not ideal
for react but we've made it work so far
and this is the only time we've run into
an issue where I just couldn't get it to
work I was spending way too much time
yesterday getting it to work I probably
should have given up on it sooner but it
just didn't even occur to me during the
stream until the very end so what I did
normally what materialized does is if
you have a select input it goes through
all the options and then it creates new
Dom nodes for new elements and it
creates a new ul and then each option
becomes an Li within that ul so that all
happens after you know with with jQuery
so that's not really registered in react
now that wasn't even the main issue so
that was one issue but the main issue
was that whenever we changed that select
input that event wasn't registering for
react so when I try to have this on
change handler to do something it
wouldn't do anything it didn't recognize
the change it would actually run it was
weird it would run twice on render that
was because it would actually render
once and run and then it would make an
API call to populate all these options
and then re render and then we'll run
another time but then when I actually
tried to change
the select input to select one of these
options it wouldn't fire off an event so
that's that's an issue with materialized
and and react so I think that the issue
is probably on the side of materialized
and how it's done it's not I don't think
it's a react issue from what I can
understand there were some some pool
requests to try to fix that but I don't
think that it seems like the maintainer
zuv materialized don't see that as a bug
and they just recommended using the
react materialized framework which is an
attempt to make materialized work with
react and turn everything into react
components so so I don't think there's
any chance anytime soon of that being
changed so just in case you're trying to
use materialized as well you can either
go the route that I did or you can try
to use react materialize instead or try
to do some type of custom fix but I'll
show you you know basically what I did
is now I'm using just a plain select
input I did do some extra styling so I
could make it fit in so let me show you
I mean obviously this doesn't look like
your default select input when you click
it this looks like browser default right
I can't really do much about this
browser default and it'll look slightly
different depending on the browser but
you know assuming I want to stick with a
select input and not try to do something
some type of custom list which I don't
really want to do it right now it would
be okay but it would be a lot of work I
think for a slight improvement and I'm
running out of time to work on this site
so I just changed things so that it
mimics the look of this search box okay
so and how I accomplished that was with
all of this it's really big mostly
because of all these vendor prefixes
which
I think if you put things within the
style JSX tag it actually Auto prefixes
for you but I had copied this over from
a previous project where I had figured
out everything I need to do to style
this in the materialized fashion so I
didn't I didn't try to redo that I just
copied it over so it's not hurting
anything to have the vendor prefixes in
there and it's working so I'm not gonna
mess with it and then I just needed to
add in this this part at the bottom let
me bring make this a bit bigger I think
is this is a bit smaller than I normally
have it so I had to add in this the
reason I couldn't put it right here in
the style JSX
tag was because of this so it thought I
was trying to incorrectly escape
something within this string because of
the slash so it wouldn't work so if you
try to use content and then you know one
of these this basically makes that that
little try upside down triangle they
call it a carrot that's the little code
to make that so if you're trying to do
something like that it won't work in
style of JSX so this code is all on
github you can check it out under the
dev branch so if you want to kind of
look into how I did this place it's not
really a lot it just looks like a lot
because the vendor prefixes and a lot of
it is just trying to override browser
default things all right so that's
pretty much it I'm gonna check the live
stream now see if there's any questions
about that before we get started
okay we have somebody card carnage I'm
not sure how to pronounce the name kar
IE KR n IE j carnage I don't know
sorry about not know not to pronounce
that but anyway says hi everybody I'm
looking for a job react job so I guess
so hopefully you you can pick up some
react knowledge on this stream if
anything you can probably pick up some
mistakes to avoid when you when you do
this my stream is really good at
demonstrating the pitfalls and mistakes
that can be made and sometimes even how
to fix them but anyway I'm not sure that
anybody watching now or in the live chat
is hiring so I don't know that I can
help you but anyway I keep keep us
updated on the job search I'd love to
hear how it goes okay
the will Frank says long time viewer
first day hey how's it going thanks for
saying hi I realized there's probably a
lot of people who watch who never speak
in a live chat which is totally cool I'm
actually am usually pretty quiet and
chats and things myself when I'm
watching so I totally understand
and maybe you're just doing other things
and not a computer yours feel like
listening or watching
but don't be shy if you can if you can
say hi that would be cool because I
noticed you know there's always the the
analytics shows that there's always way
more viewers than people talking in the
live chat and today we actually have
fewer of yours than we've been having
normally so I don't know what happened
maybe the topic is not great today it's
still a decent amount of years though so
I think we have like 40 right now which
is I mean that's I'm always amazed that
anybody wants to watch me cuz
forty or forty three now cool person I
see react a Fabian how's it going
haha Evo says hi Jesse not James's son
hey how's it going that yesterday Evo
accidentally called me James in the chat
which was just fine that it didn't
bother me bill says hey it worked but
listening in the background today
awesome
that's that's cool that's why I imagine
that's probably a lot of people may be
in the same situation especially if
they're in a similar time zone to where
I'm at because this is the time when
people are normally at work
John said is it not always with the more
simple coding it saves the day all these
things like reactor webpack other
complex systems for me at least now is
overkill yeah I I agree to some extent
that I'll react webpack all that stuff
increases the complexity and increases
the possibility for bugs so if you don't
need to use those things for what you're
trying to accomplish you you are
probably better off not using them but
for a lot even you know if you're trying
to learn them there's no reason not to
do a small project with it because if if
your purpose is not just to produce a
product if your purpose is to learn then
you know make something simple with
react I I actually uh a few weeks ago
when I was on vacation I built the free
code camp weather app I don't know if
you all remember that challenge is kind
of early on in free code camp challenges
but I built that I rebuild it and react
I had built it once just with some
jQuery and I did it just simply to get
some practice and to learn it definitely
doesn't need to be built and react but
but anyway to speak to John's point that
definitely was the case this time with
materialize it was trying to do all this
other stuff and beyond what a normal
select input does and you know the
select input that's been in HTML for for
years and years worked fine for this use
case so it was definitely the solution
and better off hey Zanna says hi hey
how's it going glad you can watch Jordan
asks how do you hook up WordPress with
react okay cool I'm going to show you
today how we hook up WordPress with
react so I'm not going to explain it
right now because we're I'll be able to
show it to you we're gonna do it during
this this stream and I'll start that in
just a minute I just wanted to say hi to
everybody and you know at the beginning
of the live chat before I get get to the
code ego says John if you have this many
modules of stuff to keep track of a tool
like web pack is a lifesaver react
is also really nice and I think that
they will become even more prevalent
yeah that's true that's a good point you
know like if your project is complex it
ends up helping to have things like
react and webpack like yesterday I
showed you all that I think it was
yesterday I showed you all that mess
that was the the jQuery site that I had
made which basically did a lot of the
same stuff that this site does but I
built it all with jQuery and it was just
a bunch of crazy spaghetti code and it's
really hard to maintain now I really
can't wait until I have the time to
rebuild that in react
so in that case using something simpler
than react which was I would argue that
jQuery is probably simpler than react at
least it's simpler to learn but that
ended up being worse as the project got
more complex so I think there ends
there's a tipping point in the project
of you know where some of these tools
actually do end up helping Zanna asks
did you debug it Zen are you talking
about the the select input thing that
was happening so I don't know maybe you
might have joined in right after I
explained it so sorry if you missed it
but basically yeah I did get it working
and I just went with a normal select
input so I just got rid of the stuff
that materialized was glowing and just
went with a normal select input
everything worked fine and I just did
some styling to make it look like it was
it fit with the materialize styling
all right so think I'm gonna I'm gonna
scan through quickly the rest to see on
the live chat and then I'm gonna get
started
okay bill bill said he watched the
replays of the last two streams and at
one point in yesterday's streams I
accidentally showed his project instead
of my project and he says it's cool
though because it was on github as
open-source so yeah sorry about that I
mean I'm glad that it's cool and
everything but I'll have to be more
careful about double-checking what I
show I try to keep everything that
shouldn't be shown on my other screens
okay so they all go asks about the Auto
prefixing the CSS inside the JSX
I'm not sure I think the I think if you
use next J s the Auto prefixing
everything comes built-in so I I don't
know I have to check it out I just
always assumed it was Auto prefixing I
thought I saw that before in my code
that it was all in a prefix but now that
I really think about it I would have to
double check to say 100% for sure so
don't take my word for it without
double-checking but I'm pretty sure it
does get Auto prefixed as long as it's
inside the style da J or the style JSX
tags okay okay so Zanna did didn't hear
the explanation the beginning so I gave
us a slightly longer explanation and I
showed the code so Zanna if you if you
get a chance later on you can watch like
the first 10 minutes of the stream or
something the recording and get a longer
explanation
okay I'll wait - Patrick centerlink
what's the link Patrick I'll check it
out of my sheep
okay
that's weird okay so this should check
this out I'm probably not gonna fix this
right now I'll do it later since I want
to do something else on the stream but
Patrick just sent this
so what browser was that that's it on
Ubuntu with with chrome okay
well that's no good so I'll have to work
on that Danny but if anybody else
checked this out let me know if you're
having anything similar happening
obviously like Chrome on a Mac it looks
like this it works blown on Ubuntu it
looks like this I mean I really want it
to work but realistically there's
probably no actual user of this site
who's like in the target audience that
would be using Ubuntu so if that's the
only place where this happens I probably
won't worry about it just because I
don't have a lot of time yet so I gotta
worry about you know the other browsers
more browser
operating system combinations more but
yeah I'm gonna have to take a look at
that although I really won't have a good
way to test it because I don't I don't
have Kubuntu and I don't even think you
can test that on browser stack off to
check I don't think you can test it on
Linux let's see
okay Patrick just said the same thing
that there's not a lot of site people
going to the site with Linux okay it's
good to know the and I'm definitely
going to check it out with some other
combinations of operating systems and
browsers devices to make sure that
there's not similar errors happening
elsewhere so thanks for sending that so
Oh actually I did want to before I
started I wanted to mention a little bit
about the net neutrality thing that's
happening so especially for those in in
the United States right now there's like
some the federal government has some
stuff going on where basically it could
end up being really bad for the internet
like things could be blocked like so I
wanted to show some of you may have
already seen this but there's these
videos that are they're really short so
I think I'm just going to show this
video quickly this net neutrality video
which we'll be able to kind of explain
things a lot better than I can and let
me try to bring this over I think it's
just only a few minutes so let me throw
this on here yeah oh it's not even it's
33 seconds so
okay so anyway that was just a really
basic of what's happening so if you're
if you're interested and just putting
your name out there as being against
this then you know check out the the URL
which was battle for the Netcom so and
today is like the official day I think
where a lot of stuff is happening to
raise awareness and kind of protest that
possibility of the internet being you
know way more regulated by companies and
different than it than it is now and
then it probably should be alright let's
see I just want to check the live chat
really quick to see what other errors
you are getting
okay so Windows 10 in chrome is the same
issue so okay so Evo says Evo's found
the error already which is awesome thank
you so much you have a color value of
inherit in the CSS rule button for input
select area which comes from
materialized okay alright so evidently
there's something being being applied
from materialize the materialized
framework that's affecting that so
oh so I'll check that out
okay let me open post the link to the
dev site again for for those either came
in a little bit later so I have a 1/3
droplet now that's running the dev
branch so I'll try to keep it updated
with the latest dev stuff so until I get
approval for the changes from the people
higher up than they I'm not gonna make
them since they're really significant
changes for for a lot of pages I'm not
I'm not just gonna try to make them live
on my own I need to get some approval
first so for now they're gonna exist
only on this at this IP address and okay
cool Evo is gonna open a github issue
with an explanation of what's going on
with that select input so I'll
definitely check that out and actually
if anyone is kind of shaky with the
JavaScript skills but is really good
with their CSS that will probably end up
being a CSS only solution that might be
good to contribute so otherwise I mean
I'm I'm sure it'd only take me a few
minutes to figure it out
but especially for new people who are
trying to get some some more things on
the github profile that might be kind of
an easy thing to do so enough of this
we're gonna work on something totally
different so I'm gonna move this off the
screen and I'm gonna do this off the
screen and what a bunch of stuff off the
screen I can keep this on the screen
also yesterday one more thing just
continuing from yesterday yesterday I
had a pool request from Rene which
switched over to using pre-act instead
of react and it made things smaller the
bundle size for production was smaller a
lot smaller so when I tried to use it on
this test server I was getting an error
I was saying R is not a function so I'm
not sure what was going on it worked
fine locally but when I tried to
actually build it and run it I was
getting there so I ended up not merging
that pool request I didn't accept it yet
I'm not saying I won't accept it but I
just need to get it working on the
actual server first so so I added I
added that to to the actual pool request
I added a comment about it so if anybody
has any ideas for that you know please
you know comment there on that on that
pool request on github ok so today what
we're gonna do
let's start with WordPress first so I'm
gonna do I'm gonna start here in our
WordPress plugin
so you've probably seen this before
this is a wordpress plugin that we're
using to make a bunch of custom post
types so here's what we what we need to
do here's the the kind of the end goal
for the user the user needs to be able
to click on a link that will be like the
title of a PDF document right so in the
about page we're going to create
something to display these links some
new section but I don't want them to
just link to PDF documents right because
that's that's no good for
search engine optimization I'm not
really sure how screen readers handle
that so I'd rather have these PDFs
converted into HTML but I also want the
PDFs available to download so I'd like a
user to be able to go to the about page
see a list of the titles of these PDFs
click on it when they click it opens up
an entirely new page on a react site
that has the contents of that PDF in
HTML and then also has a button to be
able to download the PDF and I want that
all to be editable from within WordPress
so we're gonna make a custom post type I
guess a PDF page post type and it needs
to have your normal title and content
fields which are there by default but
then we're gonna add one custom field
that's going to be the URL of the PDF
and actually we should probably might
want to do the title field should be
good I kind of thought maybe we might
want to do a separate field for PDF
title but I think the title field should
be enough that we could pull into use
for the link text so that should that's
all we need to do on the wordpress side
and then we'll come in we'll build the
the page that that's going to be
populated we'll build out the section
that needs to be in the about page and
then we'll update our code in our server
das file to direct people to the right
place and make the right API call to get
that data so let me
copy so I think you you I've done this
before on a stream so I'm just gonna
copy this did I get the I don't know if
I got the top part so I'm doing it again
so I'm going to copy this and paste it
now I'm just gonna change all of these
and I wanted to say instead what did I
say was a PDF PDF page yeah I think
that'll I think that'll be obvious to
the people who are editing it what I
would that is okay so this is how it
will display these are all the display
names that'll be like in the WordPress
admin panel and then these are the names
that'll be in the code so let's make PDF
all right so now I'm gonna say that oops
actually I'm not gonna save it okay copy
this let me bring over my WordPress
admin panel here so I need to login I
just let me bring this over and I need
to upgrade to the newest version so I
was just waiting to do a backup so I
have one of my co-workers purchase a
subscription for this backup plug-in
that we can use on and I think an
unlimited amount of site so I'm just
waiting to get the info about how to
install that because generally you don't
want to really do too many updates on a
wordpress site without backing it up
I've done a lot of updates on small
sites without backing up and I've never
actually had anything happen but it's a
good practice to to do the backups if
you can so you can manually you don't
need a plug-in you can manually do the
backups but I don't have like PHP
myadmin installed or anything like that
so I just I don't really feel like doing
the backups from the command line and
I'm not even sure I have SSH access to
this droplet so let's go actually that I
have no idea why that I've keeping this
so small we'll make it a bit bigger and
I'll increase the size so y'all can see
what's going on so I'm gonna go into
plugins here and I'm gonna find I passed
it up there you see I custom types
that's our plug-in and I'm gonna edit
now if I did have I don't I don't really
have any access to this server either
FTP access or SSH for some reason the
accesses and it isn't working I didn't
set this up someone else set it up and
so I just never figured out what the
issue was so this is why I'm updating
the plug-in like this normally I
wouldn't update like this I would
probably probably use FTP
and just open the file directly in my
editor but this works too so all I've
done is just copy and paste of the new
stuff I'm going to update it also I mean
normally it wouldn't be a great idea to
update stuff on a live WordPress
installation anyway I'm pretty confident
though since we we changed a minor thing
that it should be fun and since
everything if you mess up something in a
plug-in you like very quickly realize
that you mess it up in WordPress like
you'll get this white I think it's like
a white screen or something and you
can't log in your site so if that
happens you want to go in with FTP or
SSH whatever you can and just rename the
plug-in folder of the plug-in that you
just changed is causing the problem and
then that'll let you get back at least
into your site and have your site
running again and then you can revert to
a previous version or whatever you
change you can revert it back and try to
figure it out best thing to do would be
to have a a dev version of WordPress
that you can test it out on first which
I did not have set up for this yet but I
may end up setting it up at some point
so let's check out our PDF pages alright
so now we have our PDF pages so you can
see it's just like a normal wordpress
post right just basic stuff we do want
to add one field though and for that I'm
gonna use a plug and I'm not gonna
custom code that so let's get on our
custom fields plugin
and we're gonna add a new group and
we'll call this PDF page info and I'm
gonna we're going to make sure that it
shows that it only applies when the post
type is equal to PDF page I'm gonna add
a field the field label is going to be
actually I was gonna make it PDF URL but
it should probably be an upload so let
me see file
okay so we will upload that I kind of
didn't want to at first because I wasn't
sure I wanted to have all the PDFs
hosted there on the site but they'll
probably be less room for error if the
PDF just gets uploaded and I can pull
the URL otherwise it's gonna be someone
manually copying and pasting or typing
out a URL and then two things could
happen that I could see either they mess
up the URL and it doesn't work or
something happens to the place where
that PDF is hosted so even if just the
change in the file name occurred then
the link wouldn't work anymore or that
server could be down or something so it
probably is better if we just have the
PDF there it within the WordPress and
it's a droplet on digitalocean I could
always upgrade the storage if I need to
if things start to get crazy
I don't really anticipate that that much
will get uploaded that I would need to
upgrade stores so this should probably
I'm actually not I'm not gonna require
this because the way we're gonna display
this the way I want to display this is I
want these pages to be just
informational pages so it's not gonna
say right away that these are just PDF
conversions the PDFs almost gonna be
like an afterthought like if you want
the PDF version here it is so in case
there's at some point down the road they
want to just include some information in
this page without actually include
having a PDF version I'm gonna make this
not required and I want to return the
file URL
and that should be it
now we can let's see I want to put this
up high after the title so it's really
obvious I do want to put this in the
standard meta box I think the seamless
kind of looks a bit nicer but it's more
familiar for users to put it in the
standard box so what what I don't need
here so I want to hide the permalink I
want to keep the content editor so when
we're only using WordPress for the API
we can hide a lot of things because they
won't really work so we don't need the
exurbs we don't need the custom fields
because this isn't talking about the
custom field we just made this would
have been if we if we added custom
fields through WordPress has kind of
like a built-in way to do custom fields
that's not nearly as user-friendly and
powerful as this plugin
we don't need discussion comments
revisions could be helpful the slug is
unnecessary authors unnecessary format
I'm gonna hide featured image for now I
don't think we'll be including images at
least a featured image and I'm not gonna
worry about categories or tags and
another track back so this is going to
simplify the UI significantly so you'll
see when we go back in there will be a
lot less than there was originally so
I'm going to publish that and now let's
go back in we'll add a new page okay see
so here's our file input so we can add a
file and actually this PDF I'm just
gonna put this PDF in just a little
have something and let's add a title
test page and let's grab some just some
some text to throw in there
and I just grabbed some some bacon ipsum
which is a taste to your version of
lorem ipsum we don't really need the
sharing buttons but I didn't see an
option to get rid of these so I'm not
worried about it now it won't make a
difference whether this is checked or
not but we can see you know really
there's it's really simple for people to
edit things in here there's not much
that can be done so I'm gonna publish
this and that's all we need to do on the
wordpress side of things so it should be
it should be enough for us just to have
this one instance of it we kinda think
there's really only one spot where we
would display more than one set of data
and that's that's one the about page so
we may have to just hard code in some
some other examples just to see what it
will look like but this should be fine
for now
so that's it for the wordpress side of
things and we'll check out the wordpress
api now just to make sure that we're
getting the data and as soon as you see
the data I'm gonna go I'm gonna check
back in the live stream because that's
kind of the end of part one of our
little mini project here so I want to
check out the PDF pages oops
was a PDF page there we go PDF page so
here we go so when we make an API call
to get a PDF page this is what we'll get
back we actually don't need all of this
data so we'll probably filter it down
because we'll just need the content and
we'll get the URL here we go here's our
PDF upload URL so that's pretty much all
we need and the title alright so we have
that and I can move this over I don't
think we need it anymore now I'm gonna
go to the live chat quickly next step is
going to be editing our about page to
give users somewhere to actually click
to get to our new page that we're gonna
make all right so I'm gonna scroll up a
bit in a live chat see what I missed
okay Evo just added the github issue
thank you so much for that the issue
about the appearance of the Select okay
Jeremy is bringing up there's a slack
channel now for for free code camp
it's FCC pair programming slack calm and
Joe says FCC just keeps getting better
every day
awesome I like that that comment
okay it looks like Zanna has included
some images of that select input as well
from Ubuntu on Firefox and Chrome okay
so it looks like on Firefox it actually
is working I'll put it on the screen
quickly so it's working but it's black
in the background so this might be a
little bit more challenging than I
thought because you know the we need it
to show up the text to show up is white
when it's selected and we can't just
simply make it black because it wouldn't
show up in Firefox so off to think that
one through a bit more to make sure that
the text is readable I'm trying to think
the last time I did this it was on a
white background so I didn't have the
same issues I mean as possible I could
just change this so that it's not on a
black background anymore if I can't find
some way to make this work and then that
would just solve the issues because we
would have a dark-colored font and it
should work all the time because this
this then would have a white background
instead so anyway we'll see actually
what do you all think about this black
bar anyway so I've gotten some feedback
from co-workers and the feedback so far
was at first it was a little jarring but
it only took you know a minute or so to
get used to it and then it was it was
okay so not great feedback I mean I
would rather have wow this looks amazing
so I'm not I'm still not sure about it
myself now that I've been looking at it
for so long I'm used to it but I just
kind of I didn't want to just all white
you know I wanted something else here to
kind of set these off you know these
controls these filters off from the rest
of the content
so if anyone has any other ideas let me
know and I'm definitely open to some
alternatives I mean I need to be careful
I can't spend too much on it so if it's
at a point where it's good enough I'll
probably just have to leave it because
we're running out of time so I don't I
don't really want to mess with it too
much but a color change shouldn't be
that big of a deal you know if I really
find a color that that I like I'm open
to spending the time to change it
okay yeah and so in regard to the slack
Channel yeah I can't so a few people are
saying they couldn't get into the slack
Channel they need an invitation or
something I had the same issue I
couldn't get into the slack Channel
either let me I think I still have it up
on my screen somewhere at least I did
I've way too many windows open I'm not
sure here it is I find it yeah so this
is what I'm getting sign-in to FCC pair
programming and when I try to sign-in I
can't
so it says contact the team
administrator and I'm not sure who the
team administrator is or what their
contact information is so has anybody
been able to get in if so how
okay his Hannah says all that is a bit
unintuitive can you just use categories
instead I'm not sure I'm trying to look
at the timestamp for that was that in
regard to to this bar here
you know Evo says I don't really like
that people are now using slack as a new
generation of email maybe I'm just
stubborn or getting old
he says I'm twenty but I just can't
really get used to it so I'm not sure
that that 20 is old I guess if you're a
kid 20 years old but yeah i'm i like
slack but I'm not sure that slack is a
actual email alternative I use slack for
different things that I would never
normally send an email for so I know
there are people saying like slacks
gonna kill email like emails that I
don't buy that I emails probably gonna
be around for a long time because
everybody's used to it it works but
slack is really cool for what it does
and so I like I like that if I want to
send a quick message to somebody that
would be a waste of time to send in an
email slack is really great for that
okay so I'm getting some feedback about
that section maybe change it from black
to the like the red color and then that
may that may look better
okay Zanna says maybe like just leave it
leave it white but add like a border a
thin border at the bottom and the top or
even like John said to make it make it
that red color
okay I'll have to try that out
oh okay I see what is n I see what
you're trying to say here so then let me
let me try to explain what I think
you're saying you could let me know if I
got it right here
so instead of having the word all right
here which doesn't really say much have
it say like categories or something and
that would that would make more sense I
did originally have it saying choose a
category but I got an error so basically
I had to like add in manually that the
the word selected into that into that
element into that option and then react
gave me a warning it wasn't really an
error message gave me a warning saying
not to do that I don't know why I
shouldn't do that but I could definitely
change that back so that category is the
first thing actually that would make
sense it would definitely work if I
would just say choose a category is the
first thing that people say it's not
going to be disabled the problem right
now is it's disabled and greyed out a
little bit I'll just make it have the
same value as all and then that way
it'll show everything if someone happens
to click on it again who cares it'll
still show everything or they would just
naturally click on all
okay yeah I think I'll do that I think I
might actually do that right now since
it's such a small change it would be
better just to do it I mean I have it
open already so let me I do want to
double check would I put my I lost my
terminal I just wanted to check to see
if I had anything that was not committed
here it is okay so it's clean you know
obviously I'm gonna start doing a lot of
stuff directly on the dead branch and
just kind of merging in all the
different branches that I've been
working on into dev like as they start
to get closer to being done
so I'll take out disabled and I'll put
in a zero and then that should
automatically make it the first option
so I say that it didn't Auto refresh
there we go so that works better you can
click all here what you want to make
sure this works if I click choose a
category it still works us all okay so
that look better
okay Patrick says get some Patrick
suggested saying all categories
Johnson's and categories yeah I think
any of that work I probably I'm just
gonna keep this just so that I don't
spend any more time on it
but anyway yeah I'm glad that that you
brought that up because okay Patrick
likes what I ended up with I'm glad you
brought that up because I it was
something I had thought of earlier and I
thought the same thing that it would be
weird and then I just kind of gotten
used to it and and just kind of forgot
about it and I never like I never wrote
it down usually make a little note in
Trello when I think something like that
but for some reason I didn't and so just
kind of forgot so it's really good to
have all these people looking at it you
know all of you looking at it and you
know just in general on a project it's
great to have other people look at it
because when you're building it you just
get used to certain things and take for
granted that people are gonna understand
it so it's really like I mean doesn't
really matter how good you are as a
developer I think that's it's just like
a natural thing is that you can't look
at it with fresh eyes like the user
would a new user because you've been
looking at it for so long I mean maybe
if you waited a year and then looked at
it again and you've forgotten it you
know that would be the only way but I
mean who has time to wait that long okay
so that looks a lot better now let me
commit that I'd hate to commit make a
commit for such a small change but the
other changes we're going to be doing
you're so unrelated that I'd rather just
just do it so so we're gonna commit
we're gonna get commit and then we're
gonna use the flag am so this will add
the file and make the message at the
same time so we don't separate it into
two steps and let's see
this is gonna change default option
resource category select okay that works
probably what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna change that
at some point so if I end up using a
select somewhere else in the site I'll
probably make this option be like a prop
that you could pass in the text for this
option I think that's the only thing
that would have to change everything
else could stay the same and it would
work
possibly like some of the colors could
end up being options that get passed in
but that would really be it then then it
would make this component like fully
reusable and as possible am I using
okay so I'm not really using any colors
here so this could stay and that would
oh yeah I am I'm using this color so
potentially I could just pull this and
include it here so that the color could
actually be a prop as well so I'm not
gonna do it now but if I do end up using
this again I'll pull that in and then it
will be reusable all right so we need to
bring up the about page cuz that's what
we're gonna be working on and let me go
back I wanna check the last shot just
really quick
let's see I'm bare toasters I wish I
could open source this HR portal page so
is that I'll bear - are you is that what
you're working on now and you not
allowed to open source it that's things
I I I definitely prefer at least now
definitely now that I'm doing streaming
I prefer to work on things that can be
open source
Patrick is bringing up the new stuff and
NPM five point two point zero is NTX
it's a new command that's really useful
so you could do like npx create react
app new app it'll grab the latest create
react app without polluting the global
node that's cool yeah I saw some stuff
on Twitter about it but I didn't really
read into it anymore so people on
Twitter seem to think it was really
really useful so I have to check that
out
hey Sebastian's here how's it going
yeah Sebastian pretty much all you
missed I kind of explained how I fixed
the select input from yesterday and I
made a custom post type with a custom
field in WordPress so we haven't really
done too much with react yet and we're
about to jump into that right now
okay so in Patrick just put a link in to
a medium article about npx so if you can
get to the live chat and check out the
the link then that should tell you a bit
more about it
I'm not even gonna attempt to read out
the link because it's super long all
right so we're on the about page the
first thing let's just look at it and
figure out where we're gonna put this
thing so here's our about page now so
let's see
all right so this will definitely can
stay down at the bottom this is the
least important section I'm not sure I'm
thinking probably we could probably put
a new section here and that would make
sense just visually it would break up
this kind of double whitespace section
since most you know we're breaking it up
everywhere else so probably another red
section something you make maybe another
another red section in between here I'll
probably give it a title just as more
information for now and then if if it
needs to change then it can change it's
not really a big deal
so that section will say more
information and then it can have its I
mean it's really just gonna have lists
of links
I don't think there's that many links
right now I think it's like at most six
or seven but it could potentially be
more so would like to think of a way
that it won't get too cluttered up if
there's more
I'll think about it let's just start to
throw in some code now and then see how
it looks and then think about right now
I'm thinking maybe just like two columns
of links and there they're gonna be Auto
populated from an API call so I'll just
have to figure out some way to
distribute them between the two rows
evenly and then hopefully the list I
mean if the list ends up being like a
hundred links it's going to be a super
long section I'm okay with that I guess
because I said I think the collaborator
section is probably not really that
helpful to users so not really not
really a big deal all right so let's go
back and unfortunately this is super
long because I haven't transferred any
of this stuff over to being pulled from
the WordPress API so it's it's all just
hard-coded in here but what I want to do
is grab the red section that we're
already using and I'll just copy and
paste that down here and then that way
we don't have to waste time typing in
code that we've already typed in so this
is a collaborator section that's the
start of it so we want to pop this in
right here and so we actually we need to
put in
this new section here
let's see where if you like container
put in another row here and we'll call
this I don't remember what I originally
was going to call this I'm just going to
put information there for now we don't
want this flourish white because
actually I never ended up building yeah
I think I don't think this is doing
anything right now this was supposed to
do something a long time ago and I guess
I never removed it that was one of the
things that just got pushed to the side
as not really necessary to get done
before we launched
okay so we'll have that and we're gonna
want two columns let's get rid of all
this we don't need it and s12 is fine
but we want to make this m6 and that'll
give us our two columns and inside here
you have EUL and then Ally
and we're gonna have an a Atrus
okay I just want to fill this in a bit
to give us an idea of what were what
it's gonna look like
okay so let's see
okay not great just look great right now
let's see so obviously we want to change
it I'll probably make these I think
it'll look a lot better if they're both
centerline obviously the the color is
gonna change to be white you probably do
with making the the font size for the
links a bit bigger and maybe like some
more space between the list items since
they're gonna be things that people are
going to want to click on I want to make
sure there's enough space especially so
on mobile people don't accidentally
click you know users with big thumbs
have trouble hitting target so I think
you usually want to have at least 48 -
yes so that's only 20 pixels tall the
click target for that's only 20 pixels
so the Li itself is even only 25 pixels
tall so we definitely want to make this
bigger increasing the font size will
help to but then maybe we'll increase
the line height so I want to at least
hit like 40 pixels and that should be
decent for for people even with with
larger thumbs okay
so hook like you remember all that so
new color
Center it increase the font size and
then we'll check it out
let's see
I think I'm just going to give this a
class this section of class of PDF links
all right and now that we have that PDF
links then we can target this down in
our style JSX section here
and let's go with make I want to make
sure I override anything that
materializes doing so otherwise I guess
I wouldn't normally need to be that
specific but I don't want to mess around
that should be specific enough there
that'll work so we want to deal it a
color of white and let's do a font size
of let's try 22 and see how that looks
we also want we want to Center it so we
want to Center that within the columns
actually we don't I'm not gonna put that
down here because we already have a
class for that I think this will work
if we do if I put on this row this might
work
to the line Center
it's just Center I think it is so I'm
trying to remember with the materialized
classes for this I think it's just
Center so let's see what that did
alright cool what did everything so here
we have it here's all our links we did
get a little bit bigger here but I think
it's still not big enough for a target
yeah so it's the only 25 pixels so I
don't know that I want to go any bigger
with the font size so maybe we'll just
add some padding to these links and then
maybe a little Morgan we'll see so down
here let's give it some padding and
let's get let's give it a pixel all
around and then between these allies
let's give normally I would flip the
order of this I don't know that it
bothers me but I guess it'll be okay for
now let's give it a margin of
[Music]
let's see
let's go I don't want a huge margin so
let's go four pixels and then zero on
the sides there so this when you only
have to the first number it first unit
is the top and bottom margin and the
second one is the left and right margin
don't know what did I do
I messed something up let me just try to
give it a refresh maybe that's all yeah
there we go
remember that when something weird
happens just refresh before you panic
alright so now we have a area that we
can click on of what is it like 40 what
was that 40 it's actually 41 over a
little bit it's actually not exactly how
I wanted it so let's mess around in dev
tools here for a little bit and see two
one so I increase this a bit and we'll
see so this is our a tag and these are L
eyes and what was happening let me try
to exaggerate this so we can really see
what's going on so let's make this
spacing bigger okay that's actually a
bit better there's like some overlap
where the click target will seem like it
was down here in the spot so that's too
much spacing but I might go with like 8
pixels
let's see weekend I don't know if you
can tell that I'll try to zoom in so
that what's happening is the click area
is kind of bleeding over into the area
of the margin so I might get rid of the
margins on the lis and just put it
directly on the a tags and see how that
is because otherwise I don't want there
to be I'd rather have there be a slight
gap of the the clink targets so let's
just pull this and for now just get rid
of that
okay so I want to see how it's working
hmm
and that's what I thought would happen
there we go so initially what had
happened is it wasn't working because of
the way it was displayed now it's
definitely working
I switched to display:block but now
that's too much so might not even need a
margin Oh actually no I definitely don't
want it to display:block because then
it's gonna go across so let's take that
out and
[Music]
now that's not gonna change it alright
I'm not gonna mess with this anymore it
works I just like oh maybe I'll actually
test it on a phone just to see maybe I'm
worrying over nothing and it would be
fine to click I think this is too much
space between the lists and the heading
here so I'm gonna remove some of that
space other than that it looks weird
because these titles are really small
but the titles are definitely gonna be
bigger everything on this project has
huge titles so I'm more worried about
having not enough space for the titles
and then wrapping onto another line okay
so we'll just leave this kind of as is
and then get rid of this space and then
we'll be done with that for now
and we'll we'll work on the page and
then obviously we're gonna want to pull
this in this date in through the API for
now lo I want to just get all the pieces
working before adding that extra
complexity of pulling in the data okay
so let me remove remove this margin for
now we'll just keep the padding let's
actually let me I want to see what's
causing this space
so it looks like we do have a margarine
on the bottom of that div but we also
have a margin on the H tag
I'll try getting rid of the well we have
a margin on the UL so we have quite a
few margins going on here if I get rid
of the margin on the h2 and on the div
that should be enough I'd rather do that
then come to mess with the UL
all right so I'm going to do some inline
Styles now and in react you can you do
inline styles as JavaScript objects so
the first bracket your in JavaScript and
then the second bracket may put you in
an object so we're gonna go
margin-bottom we're gonna camelcase it
and we're gonna say zero and then I'm
just gonna copy that and paste it on
this h2 as well and let's see and that
did not any refresh okay let me restart
my server and since I'm restarting it
this would be a good time to check in
with the live chat
okay so John has says how about instead
of a new section to break up the white
space you just had a thin red bar above
collaborators on the about page
minimalistic and the page content seems
filled up enough okay I mean I I
obviously didn't see that before I
already did this so I'm gonna keep I
probably keep this section the same
because I already just made it but I
actually kind of liked that idea I'm
gonna keep that in mind
for if I need to add other sections
because I don't like being tied into
like always having to break things up in
the same way John so we have two John's
so the first round I just talked to is
John be the next one this is John John
Hanson says the API data I'm guessing
JSON yes it's JSON is this type of file
difficult to gzip from the server the
project I built went live but all
testing shows JSON only file type not
compressed done hmm I don't actually
don't have experience with that
can you can you gzip JSON files from the
server I don't I don't know does anybody
have any experience with that
all right Zanna thanks for answering the
the question about the editor
Patrick said Patrick said that says yes
he likes this question when it gets this
question we are getting dangerously far
and we were getting dangerously far into
the stream without someone asking which
would break the streak of every stream
so thanks yes thanks for asking that I
honestly don't know if it's been asked
every stream I'd have to go back and
watch them which I probably won't do
because as is the case I think with most
people but the sound of my own voice
just sounds really weird so I usually
don't watch my streams often
occasionally I'll watch just to see if I
can like improve things sometimes I
watch to see if I'm saying filler words
a lot like um and things which I do and
I try to work on huh but it's been a
streak of enough episodes that I think
we have an official streak going so
we'll just we'll just try to keep it
going well we are an hour in already
crazy actually even more than an hour
and when did I start I started it too
huh okay
John Henson says is it not 44 pixel
height and the width minimum for four
button links are the reason for using
pixels over em2 your website I'm not
really sure why you would want to use
eeehm or pixels I'm just used to pixels
so I can guess I can usually visualize
how many pixels the thing will be on the
screen because I'm used to pixels I'm
not good at visualizing at all what
eeehm would be so that's why I use
pixels
the only other unit I ever use are vh +
VW that's also easy to visualize because
it's just a percentage of the screen but
I'm sure it's probably whatever you used
to would be what you end up using unless
there's some other other reason why you
would want to use a different unit on
jar says using REM or e/m is a good
practice so yeah I just I see a lot of
people using it I'm just not sure why
what the benefit is to using it so if
anybody knows I'd be open to to hearing
about the benefit to using that I don't
really know that I would switch at this
point since I'm so used to using text
the benefit would have to be really big
for me to try to switch right now since
I'm I've gotten really good at just
being able to visualize things in in
pixels so I would need a really good
reason to switch from it
Oh someone's name in the lab chat is
inside the matrix that's awesome a great
name I used to be a huge matrix fan like
back you know when the first matrix came
out
oh no way all right so bill says there's
an app called like so that you can start
when you do a stream that will help
analyze use of filler words I'm gonna
have to look that up because I listened
really early on in one of my first
streams I listened through the whole
thing and I couldn't stand it
I used the word um so often it drove me
nuts and then on the next stream I
apologized profusely to everyone for
making them sit through all of that so I
really made an effort afterwards to stop
that but I think I'm slipping back into
it especially on days like this where
I'm pretty tired and I'm mostly focusing
on on the code so once I get started and
I'm talking about something it's usually
better but what I'm trying to code and
talk at the same time or read things off
of the live chat I do say I'm a lot I
guess that's normal but I'd still like
to quit doing it if I could
jonbi says I was so upset they didn't
name the sequel's the matrices so this
equals to the matrix I like that one
Jeremy says I don't even know this
filler words my dude so cool yeah I
actually read a study where they said
that so some people tried to stop using
filler words by talking more slowly and
pausing instead of using filler words
but they did a study where people were
more I wanna say how did it go basically
people had a much more negative view of
speakers who took long pauses then of
speakers who use filler words so if it's
a choice between pausing and filler
words you're better off using filler
words so I guess I guess it could be
worse than using filler words
all right so let me get back to this so
this is for now good enough so that we
can click on it and make sure it goes to
the right place which is all I really am
going for for now so now the next step
is going to be let me commit this first
and where we got
okay
it's weird out this keeps doing it every
time the hot module reloading happens it
doesn't load all the styles that's so
weird
alright so now let's go back to the code
we're gonna have to make a new page and
next J s and I want to use one of these
pages as a head start so I think these
pages are pretty much the same single
event single news the news page is
probably what I want
yeah this page has some extra stuff that
I don't want to have to change that so
the news page I think is more basic
am i pulling in I am pulling in some
stuff that I didn't add like the SEO
description
I don't even think I'm ended up making
that text I think we're fine I'll copy
this page and we use that to make our
new page here so I'm gonna call this PDF
page don't yes
no actually okay it shouldn't matter
what the name of the pages now that I
think about it
and maybe it will
I gotta check out my server file for a
second hold on okay so
what I want to check is with this goes
down so let me check out our events page
real quick I just wanted I'm worried
about what's gonna show up in the URL so
I can't remember how it shows up okay so
this does show up is events okay
okay I see where I put it so I so I can
put whatever I want right there so it
doesn't even really matter what's here
okay that works let me was I know it's
right here
PDF I guess I'll hyphenated since I was
already hyphenating stuff but now that I
think about it it doesn't I don't know
that it makes much sense probably should
have been camel casing this I think the
only reason I hyphenated it was because
I'm in the pages folder and normally
whatever the titles here and the pages
end up being URLs and in URLs you're
more likely to see hyphens and not
obviously not camel case so PDF pages I
should say PDF page give me a single
page to PDF page such as okay so now we
have our PDF page and I can paste in all
of this stuff and let me make sure that
I really need this
so I don't want posts what I want are
PDF what was that PDF page we brought
this over didn't we I think I'm maybe I
must have moved it over again
I couldn't remember I think it's just
PDF page is what we put in a the API
call so we're gonna filter
by our ID which is actually gonna end up
being the slug
we're not gonna need so this is where I
filter out what we actually need
I don't need taxonomy x' I need content
I don't need the excerpt I'm gonna keep
it the ID you know actually I don't know
if that I even need the ID I don't need
tags or categories we're not gonna have
an image any featured media all right so
that's all we need this will cut out a
lot of the other stuff now I need to
make sure that I get rid of those things
down here if I was using them so this
works we don't want let's see what the
information this description tag
obviously we're not getting anything
from the description tag because we're
not pulling that in so I guess I can
take it out for now just make things
more simple I might put it in later on
and I'm gonna pass in
you don't need that
now we got our error page if we need it
that are sticking of we're gonna we're
not gonna have an image for now we're
not gonna have an image but we might add
an image to just have the same image for
all the info pages for now I think it'll
be fine we'll just put in just kind of
like a normal title so let's just do an
h1 and do there's something we'll have
to set it as will need to use
dangerously set enter HTML because it's
it's possible that
sorry I just stuffed in the middle of
the thought so basically it's possible
that there could be characters that
wouldn't show up properly if we just put
this props title rendered inside the tag
so that's why we do dangerous asset
enter HTML because sometimes there's
special characters that don't render
properly or if I can just close this
we'll try it out we'll see how that
looks I might have to put that in its
own row to make it show up better but it
should work there and drops a 2-0 I
guess has to put 0 in here okay we're
getting the data I should probably use
destructuring to get rid of all this but
I'm not I'm not worried about it right
now there's not really a lot going on
okay that's good for now this will give
us enough to see obviously we're gonna
have to do something with the URL and
have some sort of button to download the
PDF but for now this will be enough to
be able to see what's going on so now we
need to go to the server da JS file and
I'm just gonna copy and paste what's
already being used here for single news
and we'll change it out and say we just
call that info I think it should be fine
I don't it's easy to change later on if
I need to as long as I don't think of
too many people of link to it actually
I'm a bit worried that they might think
info is too informal
it's kind of kind of a pretty formal
type of thing type of organisation that
this site's being made for I don't want
to put information because they just
make it unnecessarily long so how about
I just put I that'll be fun I mean
YouTube just has a C and their custom
URLs for channels so I think that's fine
I could put a P for PDF but like I said
up I don't want it to be thought that
this page is you know just a transition
of a PDF I want the PDF to be thought of
as the secondary thing
the original plan well that I was told
is that it was just going to be a bunch
of links to PDFs but that's not really a
good thing to do on the web it's it's
hard you can't search through that
content search engines can't see it at
least all the content within so so I
argued passionately against that idea
and so this is this is what was agreed
upon so we need to make this our PDF
page per mg okay so this is gonna pass
the name so we just need to make sure
when we make our links the name the slug
for that post is what comes after this
in the well after this in the URL so
this ID part needs to be the slug when
we format our URLs for the about page
and then everything should work so I'm
gonna save that and I'm gonna make sure
that I say this as well since we changed
the server I need to restart it and I
just need to make sure of the the slug
so I don't know where I put my I'm just
gonna go over to my wordpress
installation here oh here we go I
finally found my data here's the data I
was looking for before so I just need
the slug as his test page and I don't
know that I was pulling in the slug no I
wasn't I need to make sure well I don't
need to pull it in here
nevermind I don't know what I was
thinking so what I need to do is use
test page as our URL that's it so I
should be able to go in here now and
type in I slash test page
and that that happened but what is going
on okay I see when I copy this page this
news page
I hadn't copied over shoot what was it
I need the side nav actually that's
really weird it shouldn't be like that
but it's a within nav that should be
taking care of that it should should
take care of the global and its side
enough so I just want to make sure
servers fine that's working fine the PDF
page I'm 14
looks like I'm I'm not bringing in
enough okay so I'm bringing in layout
within layout nav should be brought in
it's that that's odd am I trying to hit
the side now somewhere else no this is
low phase you
all right so I shouldn't have to do this
but I think I'm just gonna do it to see
if this gets rid of the problem
I mean maybe there's something that's
going on because it's a parameterised
route that I don't know who knows but if
this fixes it and that's all I have to
do then I'm happy about that you know it
didn't
all right so
that's really odd
so I want to check out and see if this
is working I know I want to compare I
want to compare this to our our file
for single events right because the
single events used to be the same as the
single news and this actually is working
so let's see what's different between
these ones I'm gonna get rid of that
that I added to the top components okay
this is interesting so in the single
event I'm not using the layout component
so that I mean that's a really big
difference Wow for the single event this
is this is kind of the old way before he
switched over to doing things like this
I'd hate to switch back to this just to
make it work but if I can't figure out
what's going on then maybe I'll have to
I'm gonna check the live chat just to
see so basically everything is pretty
much working like we wanted to we're
getting it kind of an error unrelated to
what the goal was having to do with the
init function for the side nav okay so
but at least at this point we've
successfully had you know you can see
the flash quickly of the content well
let me let me restart this dev server so
we can see it so you can quickly see the
flash of content that comes up and it is
the content for the page it says test
page it has our lorem ipsum so that's
working so I guess it's it's mission
accomplished kind of for what we wanted
to do now I just need to figure this out
so I'm gonna go back in the live chat
and see if you all have given me any
ideas about the problem or if there's
any questions that I can answer now
since this is now already two hours in
it might be a good time to just you know
answer some questions and and finish up
since since I've accomplished what I
wanted to for this dream and then I'll
just fix this before I leave today or
tomorrow morning
okay so we were having a discussion
about fonts the units for fonts of
pixels versus a.m. and Zanna says the
idea is you you ever want to change your
font size you just changed it once and
all EMS will just use it how does
anybody do you say EMS or do you say Ms
I'm not really sure I've ever heard it
pronounced so I don't know let me know
okay so basically the pixels are won't
won't respond so it's just much easier
to scale your fonts up or down okay
okay cool thanks Zanna sent me a link
from CSS tricks so thanks thanks for
sending that as more information about
the whole font units discussion so
anyway that's cool I mean that's pretty
legit reason for using it so like I said
before not sure that I'll switch right
away
it might be more of a gradual thing but
that's pretty decent decent reason I'll
just have to get an idea of like what
what pixel size compares to the near the
rem-3 M's
okay Umberto says at least from what I
understand and the the the REM unit is
compound the compounded scale of the
font so if you have REM styles nested it
will keep scaling to the most recently
scaled size then Zanna says so pixels at
the root REM for components and then EMS
for text okay I'll definitely have to
learn some more and give this some more
thought before I start implementing it
but it definitely seems like there's
some advantages to it
okay Alberto says the dev tips youtube
channel has a good explanation so
actually I off to watch that I really
like the dev stiffs channel so if anyone
wants some a good resource for learning
like CSS and some more design related
stuff check out the dev tips channel I
the the guy who does that
he doesn't do many videos anymore he got
a job at Google and is just really busy
so I haven't seen very many videos from
him lately but his old videos are still
really good and pretty relevant it's not
like CSS changes that often and a lot of
what he does is mostly CSS so I think
they're still useful and he's pretty
entertaining too easy to listen to
Travis that's his name I'm pretty sure
the guy from dev tips is his name is
Travis okay Santa says there's this
whole debate over the pixels okay so so
maybe I've stepped in here into some
some turbulent waters here with with
this debate so I'll have to I definitely
won't have time to study up on this
right now because I gotta get this site
it done but that'll be on the list I may
have time to watch the
tips video though because I could do
that while I'm doing other things
multitask a bit alright we had another
question about the code editor Thank You
Zanna for answering the question again
John Hanson says innerhtml found found
that out the hard way there's the
special characters yeah so that was back
when we were I was referencing using
dangerously set innerhtml for stuff so
like for the title and for the content
here so it sounds like you shouldn't use
it and I think I'm pretty sure at some
point on a stream or something I had
someone who was like a little bit upset
that I was using this but my thinking is
well number one like what else are you
gonna do like this this comes through
and there's special characters in it it
gives you like the character codes and
study actual characters and it's it's
unreadable you can't you can't have that
also as long as you control what data is
coming in here which which I do then
there's no reason not to use that you
wouldn't just pull in random data from
somewhere like you'd never want to pull
in data that a user could enter you know
just some random user could enter
because maybe it would be you could do
some malicious type of stuff with
JavaScript but in this case you know
this is the proper way to do it it just
happens to be named this crazy name
dangerously set in HTML just to warn
people but if you know what you're doing
then there's no reason not to use it
Philip Philip B don't worry about asking
the question about the editor that's
it's like I totally don't mind when
people ask about the editor it's just
kind of like a running joke here because
everybody asks about the editor so I've
gotten so many questions about it that
we started joking that we need to have
like a chatbot and this job would would
be just to say what what the editor is
and like made with theme and plugins and
stuff amusing so but don't don't feel
bad at all I know I used to think the
same when I was kind of beginning and
starting out that was what I wanted to
know all the time when I saw somebody's
YouTube video I was always too kind of
too embarrassed and shy to ask in a
youtube comment so I always was like
searching through the comments hoping to
somebody else ask the question and then
I'd be able to find out what the editor
is so I totally understand the desire to
know what's going on with with other
people's code editors okay and then
someone whose name starts with F and
then there's a lot of numbers
anyone want to explain exactly what he
was working on so I'll try to give a
really really fast summary of what I've
been doing but I've been streaming for
over two hours now so it's gonna be
tough to sum it all up but basically I
made a custom post type in WordPress
with a custom field and then I exposed
that data by the WordPress API I then
pulled that data into a react website
that was also using next jazz I use some
custom routing in addition to the
routing that's there by default for next
G is to do what's called parameterised
routing so that I can populate a like a
template react jazz template based on
the post slug in WordPress and do an API
call to get the data from just that slug
that way it doesn't matter you
how many pieces of data are in there
there will always be another page there
will always have a nice-looking URL
based on the the slug for that
particular post so thanks that actually
wasn't bad I thought it would take me
longer to explain it so I'm not sure how
how much since that made just such a
quick explanation but that's basically
what was done along the way we talked
about some other things too but in terms
of code that's what we did
actually I didn't notice it Philip so
Phil you just started coding yesterday
so awesome welcome to coding and I'm not
sure Philips in I didn't see Philip say
say anything else so I hope I hope you
didn't leave Philip but if you're still
here
welcome to coding and that's really cool
that you're getting involved so right
now we're at a point in the stream where
we were kind of at an advanced level but
every time I start a new project I'll
start out with some basics so there's
always going to be some basic things
that even someone who's very new could
probably benefit from so you know check
out some of the videos like the titles
of some previous live streams and you
know if the title is something that
interests you you know check it out
there's definitely some beginner level
stuff in there and I definitely don't be
afraid to ask any questions and the live
chat or in the comments of the videos
you can even direct message me on
Twitter I'd be happy to you know give
you some advice if you need it
John Hanson said I like how we see
Jessie struggle that's how it's done
I'm glad you like Amy struggle is that's
what a lot of the stream is me
struggling is when I'm not on the stream
I don't have nearly as many issues but
believe it or not I usually get a lot
done and don't run into so many problems
for some reason especially lately the
streams have been really difficult and
I've just had these like errors and
stuff pop up and things just not working
out which is fine it probably makes the
stream a bit more entertaining and more
interactive because you are trying to
help me fix it if I just flew through
everything and got it all done really
quickly it it I don't think that would
be as good for the stream it might be
better for my project but not not great
for this drain okay so we get some
commentary here on the pronunciation so
okay so we have e m we have M Janice's
M's Sara's heard it at M's hey Sarah I'm
not sure that I've seen you in the chat
before so welcome Sarah okay so maybe
I'll say m's now it seems like the the
MS one out in the live chat so the the
CSS unit that spelled e/m I will
pronounce M from now
I'll evil s about the format that the
content comes through with a dangerously
set innerhtml property so if you have
content coming in that has HTML tags and
you don't want those HTML tags to be
displayed you know literally on the
screen then you use dangerously set
enter HTML then the HTML gets evaluated
like it should by the browser you know
so all your tags will work properly so
it'll it'll be viewed as actual HTML
content instead of just a string
it's said that made you say we should we
should call it live coding with Jesse
and the atom editor and then no more
questions we just put some text in the
corner Eva says she's pathetic yeah yeah
I don't know I don't mind the question I
think it's kind of fun I I really I
don't think I want to put it anywhere
that I'm using atom editor I think it
would be more fun to just see how many
times people ask the question I'm not
annoyed by it yet so if I ever do get
annoyed maybe then I can have something
in on the screen I already have
something in the description for the for
the videos it's it's there somewhere if
you just have to read the description
and Amica so sorry if i'm pronouncing
that wrong it's eme ka so let me know if
I'm pronouncing it wrong so a Mika says
hello hey not sure I'm not sure if I've
seen you in the chat before so welcome
if this is your first time chatting
okay so Amica want to know if the code
editor does some sort of live preview or
any kind of preview so by default I
don't think it it uses it does a preview
there's probably some sort of plug-in
they could do a preview so right now
like I'm running a development server on
my computer and it does it like reloads
everything which you can't see it right
now because I have this error message on
the screen so it's not it's not coming
from the editor but if you if you really
wanted an editor that could give you a
live preview just want to think of which
one would do that well I know like there
are some cloud editors that do that like
cloud 9 is a cloud editor that does that
should I think desktop I guess like
Dreamweaver does that I don't know that
I would recommend using Dreamweaver but
there may be there's a lot of plugins
I'm using Adam and there's a lot of
plug-ins for it so maybe able to do that
Sabo so SSD a bow or [ __ ] so SE [ __ ] must
try to pronounce em I'm gonna say Sabo
for now since you're still doing this I
left the stream maybe two hours ago yeah
I am still doing this
sometimes the streams are quite long
there's some surprise you just don't
post the editor and plugins used to make
the video about it in the info I did I
do I have the editor I have a I'm pretty
sure I have a link to the editor in the
info I don't have the plugins the I
showed all the plugins yesterday on the
stream I keep intending to make a like a
recorded video for my own youtube
channel where I go through how I have
Adams set up and I go through all the
plugins and everything I just haven't
had time to do it yet
okay so the the person with lots of
numbers in their name and the live chat
asks can you summarize this project for
me yeah I'll try to do click summary
it's it's a react website that's built
using next Jas which is kind of like a
scaffolding tool for react that comes
built in with routing and server-side
rendering so it's a react site that's
pulling data from a wordpress site the
WordPress site has no like publicly
visible face to it it's just being used
as a content management system so that
users who have no coding skills can put
in the data easily and then that data
comes into the react site it's displayed
it looks nice it runs quickly that's
pretty much it
I mean there's not really it's pretty
straightforward there's some other stuff
involved like we're doing load balancing
between two different node servers the
WordPress installation is on a separate
server so there's some some extra stuff
that's going on that may be a bit beyond
like just a really basic project but
that's pretty much it
yeah the stream will be available to
watch so add a question if the stream is
available so it will be available to
watch usually within a few minutes after
I end the stream you can watch the
recording and I just saw that Patrick
already answered that so thanks Patrick
inside the matrix that says you should
make a counter in the corner for how
many times it's asked for people asking
about the editor that would be really
cool
okay so so amicus question about editors
that have a built-in preview thing so
Sabo says brackets has a built-in
preview that works with Chrome's a
built-in plugin and Sara says Adam has
one a plug-in as well so awesome Thanks
thanks for that information that's
definitely a better answer for Annika
then then I had oh and John Hanson says
that Adam does have a built-in
development preview so that's cool I
didn't realize that the Adam theme I'm
using is called the SETI theme its SETI
the SETI theme inside the matrix says I
use the live server plug-in and Adam and
Visual Studio code to see live preview
okay so that's I guess you can check out
that plugin
so that's uh that's pretty much all for
the live chat really I think I did a
good job of keeping up with everything
so normally I go back through the live
chat and answer questions but since I
kind of stopped at several points and
answered questions I don't think I need
to go back if I did miss your question I
I'm sorry about that do you can put it
in the comments for this video and I'll
answer it later on or you can just
direct message me on twitter my the link
to my twitter is in the description for
the video so i think i'm going to end
because the stream has been going on for
almost two and a half hours now so it's
going to be a very long stream and I'll
figure out what's going on with this and
I'll let you all know tomorrow what the
problem ended up being and that's it so
if anybody has actually I got something
else in the lab chest
see
inside the matrix's sorry I couldn't
help with the air
I'm not learned and react or next yet
yeah oh don't worry about it yeah I'm
like I'll figure it out and you all
helped me so much don't ever worry about
not being able to help with a problem
because I've gotten so much help and so
much great information from you all and
in the live chat and and so much
encouragement too so you all have been
great actually I mentioned at the
beginning of the the stream that I had
submitted proposals for a talk to a
bunch of conferences last night and you
can if you check out a tweet I had like
last night so it still should be up at
the top in my Twitter you can actually
there's a link to see what the
presentation is but just to save you the
trip the the title of the the talk I'm
pretty sure I titled it something like
how live coding changed my life or
something like that so it's really cool
and basically it's all because of you
it's not it's not actually the act of
coding while talking it's it's all of
you it's the interaction I've had with
you all and how encouraging you've been
and hopefully you've been in the
community that's been built up so that's
really the amazing thing that I think is
it's just really it's really unique you
know something I've never had before I
usually work alone hey see you later
Zanna then asked to go so I'm saying she
said goodbye in the lab chat Oh see you
hopefully tomorrow you can make it for
the stream so anyway that's I always
kind of never really knew what I would
talk about at a conference that I could
talk about maybe better than other
people but I think this is something
because I've experienced this now in
this community so so I finally have
something that I think it's worth you
know I could do a good job and really
you know tell people something that's
that could be valuable
I think I did apply to do a talk about
next using next Jas with an API and all
kind of stuff and react but I think
there's a lot of other people that could
give a talk like that too and probably
better than me so I'd be happy to give
that talk it would be more technical but
I suppose it wouldn't be quite as unique
as what I could could talk about in
terms of the you know the live coding
yeah so Jana asked where is the talk at
so I don't really know I I apply to some
some talks in the United States one in
in England and oh no I don't have the
talk on my channel yet so I haven't you
know fully like thought out everything I
would say I definitely have a lot of
what I would say you know kind of in my
head but if I get accepted to a
conference to do it then I probably you
know I'll do it all I was thinking I
might even do like practice as a
livestream you know just kind of
practice the talk and get feedback
before I actually have to give it at a
conference so maybe I'll do that so I
don't know I've never spoken at a
conference at a tech conference before
and so we'll see I might not get
accepted at all but I think I'll
probably just keep applying you know as
I see things come up just keep applying
to or submitting talk ideas and maybe
I'll get one and maybe we could actually
think it would be really cool if I got
to go somewhere that was like near where
one of one of you lived and then could
have like an eat up or something of you
know like freak freak out camp people or
something that would be kind of fun but
I don't know we'll see I think there's a
conference in Argentina that I'm going
to apply to as well but they want you to
do like a three-minute video telling why
you should be there so I need to make
the video first like what else where
else I applied some places in Florida in
the United States
I think conference in New York
Tennessee Washington DC so kind of like
all different places but anyway I don't
want to I don't want to just kind of go
on and on with with talking so I'm gonna
wrap this up if anybody has any advice
for me in terms of trying to get
accepted into conferences that would be
really awesome even if you just want to
check out that link on Twitter to what I
said to try to get in the conference I
mean if you if you have any advice you
know for just kind of the way I
presented my idea about how I could do
it better I'd really appreciate that cuz
I don't know I think it would be really
cool to share that like what's going on
here with our little community with with
more people I think it'd be really
really helpful if like more people did
did things like this so anyway is that's
it that's all I got for today oh I'll be
back tomorrow at 2 p.m. Eastern time and
and until then have a great day see
y'all tomorrow